President Trump just launched a
blistering attack on a key European ally
at the start of a two-day NATO summit
mr. Trump called france's president in
his words very nasty we're saying last
month that NATO was suffering brain
death without strong US leadership the
president also talked about next week's
British election which Britain's Prime
Minister had asked him not to do and he
repeated his long-standing attacks on
Democrats in Washington who he say
should be and who say he should be
impeached Paula Reid is in London
traveling with the president Paula
what's the president trying to
accomplish here
good morning Anthony well the president
is keeping us guessing he arrived here
in London with every incentive to create
a distraction from the impeachment
inquiry back at home and rally his base
by attacking NATO but this morning the
president who has repeatedly threatened
to withdraw from the alliance praised
NATO's mission and defended the alliance
against attacks from France I believe
we're gonna have a tremendous couple of
days but very big very important
president Trump kicked off the two-day
NATO meeting with breakfast alongside
NATO secretary-general Jens Stoltenberg
we are making progress but president
Trump still could not escape questions
about the impeachment inquiry the 70
year old NATO alliance was founded to
defend Europe from the Soviet Union
today it's supposed to be a unified
effort to guarantee the freedom and
safety of Ally countries but there's
plenty of infighting and unfair because
the United States is paying 4% and some
people could say 4.3 percent of the
largest GDP there is in the world by far
President Trump once again attacked
other NATO members who he says are not
contributing enough the u.s. itself is
reducing its contribution to NATO's
central budget we've increased
Matthews of things by a hundred and
thirty billion dollars it was going down
for most of 20 years the president's
criticism is rippling through the
organization
well with everything miss you last month
French president Emmanuel macron shocked
the alliance by declaring NATO had
suffered brain death because of the lack
of US leadership mr. Trump and their
Krone will meet later this afternoon we
have very close relationships and
friendships with the United States
Britain's Prime Minister is trying to
steer clear of President Trump during
his visit he offered a warning to mr.
Trump who is not popular in the UK to
stay out of the upcoming general
election but we don't do it
traditionally his is getting involved in
each other's election Kaspar heat
President Trump said this morning he
will stay out of the UK election because
he doesn't want to complicate it
now this afternoon he will join Prince
Charles and his wife Camilla for tea
followed by a reception with a queen
here at Buckingham Palace Tony all right
Paula thank you very much